[Music]
are any of you guys at all like even a
tiny little bit curious about how the
royal family lives their lives yes I
watch videos the real [ __ ] though on how
these people spend money just the rich
and famous and like I just watched one
on Kim jong-un it's pretty crazy
I watched another one on keep going I
forgot I don't care about their weddings
and [ __ ] I want to know what the real
[ __ ] going on behind the scenes yeah I'm
wanting to start watching the crown cuz
they say that it's like kind of really
well in front of me I have 40 rules that
you probably didn't know royal children
have to follow oh is that why
what's-his-face and what's her face
we're like I don't want to be this
anymore
too many rules yeah that's why Prince
Andrew was like I just want to [ __ ]
young young girls really young girl
really young girls yeah and I want
Jeffrey Epstein like I don't believe in
these rules there's a lot of rule I just
want young prostitute yeah give me young
[ __ ] please royal rules yeah that's
right I think that what he's talking
about there boom Prince Harry [ __ ] is
why I'm sorry not true Prince Andrew
[ __ ] is why Prince Harry and also Meghan
Marcus moved out yeah we're trying to be
up yeah a part of this pedophile ring
we're protesting this that [ __ ] so yeah
we'll go into Canada there's too many
secrets that [ __ ] yeah
okay well I'm sorry to disappoint where
we don't have any of that juicy this one
really quickly clarify I think Jeffrey
Epstein killed himself and the security
cameras malfunctioned okay they
malfunction is a complete there's a
complete error yeah that happens all the
time
okay number one on this list is that
their birth must be announced to the
public when they're born so they have
like this sign signage outside
outside of the hospital and like there I
know you can't really read it but it
says like Her Royal Highness the
Princess of Wales was safely delivered
of a stun at 9:03 p.m. today Her Royal
Highness and her child are both doing
well so it's an example of one of the
birth announcements so that's like a
rule then even before like alright I
guess the moment that they're born these
royal children have to pause like oh gee
IG feels like I feel like we all do that
nowadays pretty much yeah
my son's varnak done no reason for Royal
Highness they didn't update this [ __ ]
digitizes social media eyes it like you
know how sometimes like coca-cola change
their logo because like yeah this is
like you know you need to make it more
like now yeah Her Royal Highness needs
an update right right the baddest [ __ ]
in town queen [ __ ] yeah queen bees the
adverse at 9:08 a.m. yeah it was a
little boy and he will be the future
King [ __ ] yep His Royal Highness enjoy
due to cruise wall Highness I hate what
about and Game of Thrones are like no
grace sounds time appropriate that's
sick in Game of Thrones milord I would
like in real life to me something that
we do then I think it's so lame like
that is like they always have before the
State of the Union it's like mr. speaker
the president say it's everyone claps
for 19 minutes long I'm like come on
guys this is not what we were supposed
to do over here that's what they do over
there okay rule number two they have to
be baptized so queen elizabeth ii is the
head of the church and as such all of
the members of her family must be
baptized even Meghan was anointed before
her wedding yeah I mean the Church of
England is like a big deal right
yep that makes sense the fake Church the
one that burned down what a fake Church
burn no no I'm part of Notre Dame it's
me oh all right right right all right we
didn't bring down well it's not even
answer and that's France I know that's
what I'm saying that's what the joke was
I think yeah yeah yeah you know at the
different countries a lot of all my mom
steps over there
okay anyway number three they must wear
the hauntin christening gown so this
particular gown was commissioned by
Queen Victoria for her first child's
christening back in 1841 and so since
then there have been I think like 60
something Royals that have worn this
particular christening gown cleanable
sixty-two royal babies over the course
of its 163 years of service five
monarchs have been baptized in that gown
do you think it keeps the magic if they
don't ever wash it well here's the thing
for reason the right row here's the
thing though in like the most recent
baptism which I think was Archie which
is Megan and Harry's baby
he wore a replica of the gown because
now it is way to the originals way too
fragile you see the first one to wear
the replica I think so that paved the
way for them to go he's also he's also
yeah not gonna be King England bro
so is it cuz he's black no he's not he's
Charles's next in line for the Secession
though we just said no Charles yes never
give it up to fight [ __ ] for all she
hate them Charles isn't as a country
favorite either exactly I think this is
what's gonna happen is I think this is
the end of the royal family because
everyone loves the Queen
but once the Queen is gone nobody really
likes Charles Charles isn't that popular
right so what's gonna happen is the the
people of England are gonna be like why
the [ __ ] are we paying millions of
dollars to keep these [ __ ] like
fortress their lifestyle aside from the
tourism because they get a lot of
[ __ ] money from tourism right because
it's one of the only like remaining
monarchs in Europe so they don't have
any government responsibilities no
they're just it's ceremonial
so like when the primary new prime
minister gets elected they go report to
the Queen but yeah really ceremonial and
other than that
my name is good there are other monarchs
in like different countries like Spain
and exactly I don't know yeah we can
relate to them more well they're there
they're the most famous royal family
yeah that's one say why are they I'll
kill the tabloids because of Princess
Diana cos all car cuz the DRAM O's and
why do people hate Prince Charles cuz
the Charles is not a he's doping gods
because he divorced late and died and
everyone kind of cheated on it and had
her killed and he has a really SH like
dry purse like he's not that his
personality in the way that he carries
himself and everything it's not good for
media back TV really boring guy really
[ __ ] boring yeah and he sit it up too
cuz he always told Princess Diana that
she looks like [ __ ] when she wears a
seatbelt yeah so she you know you set
that up wow it's like you know you don't
look that pretty we have that seems her
line fold over your bloody hair no back
then in the 80s they had the one where
you close the door in moving on so the
next role is royal children must or the
Royal women of the family must curtsy
upon the first time seeing the Queen on
any given day so the first time you see
the Queen in every day that you see her
you feel as a woman you must Kurt did
the guys have to do anything
guys guys to curtsy not at the ballot
bowel or something right yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] cool man that's
and also the next rule is that they are
not allowed to call the Queen gramma so
it's not that harsh because they
actually call her granny or Ganga oh
okay only not that one word you did she
said herself she was like I hate being
called grandma there are a lot of
grandma's that hate being called grandma
like for example my grandma actually she
did if we accidentally call her I will
eat that we had to call her tithi why
did she she is old yeah what's your
stance on that me person yeah like once
you're at that age of like 60 plus right
call me what I am that tool I am a
grandma if your grandma I'm cool with
even grandma but I'd be cool with
grandma what I do because they mentioned
that Prince William he used to refer to
her as Gary instead of grandma or forget
cuz he couldn't say it can you call her
Gary never know why I don't even know
that's weird
I'm into it oh how would it be a part of
the royal family but like the head of it
it sounds fun I think it's such a signal
lounge
sounds like a living hell like you know
how how insanely oh I guess you guys
don't really know because it mainly
lives in girl world mostly but like that
whole like that like backstabbing like
bitter like frenemy like political like
ugly like I exist some guys to within
all powerful dynamics yeah I'd like a
lot of politics like high school
pettiness I think in the royal family is
like times a million
you think it hundred million dollars a
year yeah I don't know I don't know if
it's Teddy because at that point I feel
like they're doing some crazy [ __ ] where
like they're backstabbing each other for
billions of no sure at that point it
does matter how much is your big ship
where's your best family heirloom worth
trillions theirs is worth goddamn
[ __ ] hundreds of millions of dollars
also like I like food let's say you live
in that place right [ __ ] about on a
bucket on pasture about how they live
Buckingham spouse or some [ __ ] Windsor
palace and like let's say they got these
nice ass historical ass rugs are they
allowed to have
bus or is that she gonna brew in some
[ __ ] arse I have servants or people
that work they are the room but they
have human room bus yeah you know so you
can't even have some cool new age [ __ ] I
don't know if they want ax is it which
heritage she has a lot of dogs
she's a courtney lady
here's thing about those expensive
heirlooms though i saw a thing recently
'no said things are only worth as much
as someone's willing to pay for it i
think you sell that [ __ ] what are you
talking about i got this boss let me
just take it away from the royal palace
and stupid celebrity auction yeah do you
know you're not a Caprio and Nicolas
Cage they're a bidding on the dinosaur
head then they and the price with all
its like $70,000 so they can have that
in the living room yeah but it's not
like you live in the palace of the Queen
and you're like hey Queen imma borrow
your you know [ __ ] ignorant you are
Nelson you know how much somebody in the
south would take you know how much
somebody in the south would pay for a
[ __ ] Dale Earnhardt used steering
wheel don't even worry about I don't
even know what any of these have said
race car driver surely all right I'm
trying to break through your ignorance
no I'm saying people especially might be
able to trash me but we will pay a lot
of money if what I know if somebody used
it I'm gonna I'm not questioning whether
or not someone would buy it I'm
questioning if they're even allowed to
move it out of the palace no true but
they're world-famous but then again they
also have a lot of property outside of
the palace - that's where they make most
of their money their junk yeah yeah
they're the biggest landlords of England
that's how they make a lot of their
money and on top of that they invest in
all over Europe Asia whatever so like
prints up their own money yeah not like
so pretty countries he has a lot of
investments in Romania like northern
Transylvania area he has a ton of
[ __ ] property there he created like a
business recently where he would get
these old school like Victorian kind of
villages and then he Airbnb z-- them so
there's a lot of their money is in real
estate and investments yeah
well Prince Charles also did a huge
marketing campaign against seat belts
when they first came off
[Music]
[Music]